a whistleblower report that led House
Democrats to him to launch an
impeachment inquiry may come out in
public later today it is a focus of a
hearing on Capitol Hill this morning
president Trump's Acting Director of
National Intelligence will answer
questions from the House Intelligence
Committee
Joseph McGuire refused for weeks to let
Congress see the whistleblower story
about a phone call where the president
asked Ukraine's President to investigate
former Vice President Joe Biden and his
son Nancy Cordes is on Capitol Hill
where some lawmakers read that the
whistleblowers complaint for the first
time last night Nancy what's going to
happen at this morning's hearing well
there could be an epic clash Anthony
Democrats are going to press the Acting
Director of National Intelligence to
explain whether anyone in the
administration pressured him to withhold
that whistleblowers report from Congress
and they also are going to want him to
authorize that with the whistleblower to
speak directly and expansively to
Congress right away
disturbing lawmakers who read the
whistleblowers complaint said it was
about 10 pages well-written and specific
it heightens our concerned and it also
gave us new leads new witnesses new
materials to follow the whistleblower is
an intelligence official who learned
about the president's Ukraine phone call
secondhand from White House officials he
or she believed that mr. Trump's request
for dirt on Joe Biden amounted to
soliciting a foreign campaign
contribution in violation of the
campaign finance laws the president was
willing to withhold military assistance
in order to extract a political
investigation that is classic abuse of
power Republicans argued Democrats were
over selling the whistleblowers claims
ukrainian President did not feel
threatened he was the target of the
phone call he felt fine with what
happened House Speaker Nancy Pelosi and
top Democrats are now debating help
quickly to introduce articles of
impeachment
and whether they should focus solely on
this Ukraine incident so what
specifically do you see as the
impeachable offense here the president
United States shaking down a foreign
leader Democrats are also discussing
whether they should have a key player
testify according to the White House
call summary President Trump repeatedly
directed the Ukrainian president to work
with his personal lawyer Rudy Giuliani
president of the Ukraine says I wasn't
pressured end of case I know over some
Republicans have told us that they
believe that while the president's
conversation was inappropriate it wasn't
impeachable but Nebraska Republican Ben
Sasse said that his colleagues shouldn't
be so quick to quote circle the wagons
and argue that there's no there there
when he believes there's actually quite
a bit in that report that is troubling
Tony all right Nancy thank you very much